want to point out a double standard that
I saw in this clip Ricky Valerie Coley
who was a transgender entrant to miss
Netherlands competition uh won the title
so a biological male has been voted Miss
Netherlands and will now take part in
Miss Universe Michaela your thoughts
I hope it was Miss Universe I'm kidding
I'm kidding it's I don't even know how
to react to these situations because
women fought so hard to get where we are
today I was just looking at the picture
of the Boston marathon runner in 1967
and it's this woman and she's being
grabbed by men on the track because
women weren't allowed to compete that's
where it started a couple things that
are incorrect about what she's talking
about number one saying that men and
women are equal is equal because there
is a natural hierarchy of things that is
supposed to go God men women children
that is the natural hierarchy
thank you